so okay uh first i'd like to thank uh
san greene frederick and uh stephen for
inviting me it's always a treat for me
to come back to bay area and um
yesterday we heard
many excellent talks on single cell
arnatic and ataxic and as you can
imagine as these technologies are
becoming mature um
you know we are improving we are
developing technology to do these
experiments that have we have done in
bulk cells with single cells so
chromatin conformation capture
experiments is one such type of
experimental protocols where we are
looking at
a
3d confirmation of single cells so my
talk is largely
basically divided into two parts in the
first part i'm going to talk about our
normalization and denoising efforts and
then in the second part i'm going to
talk about our efforts in integrating
this type of data with other
with other data single cell data
modalities so
for this audience uh most of this is
probably familiar but just to make sure
we are all on the same page
i'll just go through the basics so if
you think about the linear structure of
the dna we have genes
proximal promoter regions digital
enhancer regions and activities of this
the genes are
regulated by interactions between
enhancers and promoters so in the last
10 years or so we have generated
catalogues of these regulatory elements
and then we have now
large-scale efforts in generating
long-range interactions
and
so the looping of the dna
the um
compression of the dna in the in the
cell
and the 3d structure is what brings
promoters and enhancers together to
facilitate gene regulation
and we for the last 10 years or so we
have had technologies high throughput
technologies that can profile these
interactions so these technologies there
are many types but they they basically
work by generating fragments that come
from both ends of these interacting
regions and then with paired and
sequencing you get one read coming from
this fragment and then one read coming
from this fragment and then we align
these um we typically these bulk assays
generate millions to billions of reads
we align these um and then uh
for the sake of uh you know summarizing
the data we generate artificial beans on
the genome and we can't you know read
pairs spanning falling into bin pairs
i'll be referring to these as locus
pairs and then we you know we quantify
the number of interactions we see
between these locus pairs and then we
represent this as what we typically
refer to by uh contact matrices um
so of course with the improvements in
single cell sequencing for the last uh
ten years or so again on and off there
has been efforts in generating this type
of data profiling these type of
interactions at the single cell level so
we have early
papers from
2013 with small number of cells and but
in the last few years these efforts have
been really scaled up um
and
so just like any other data high
throughput data coming from
a particular technology uh single cell
high c has its own
unique features some of these are very
similar to what we observe in rna-seq so
this is what a typical bulk ic data
might look like and we have you know
heard about sparsity we know about
sparsely in single cell sequencing so
not so surprisingly we see that we see
it in a single cell high c as well uh
you know
high depth um
contact count matrix might look like
this where you are you know getting the
broad structures but you have much more
sparsity compared to the bulk
and if you go to a lower that
single cell high c a contact matrix then
you might get something that looks much
much sparser so the point is that yes
this data is sparse just like single
serenasiq but this varsity level is
much more larger
because we are looking at a larger space
of the genome and then you know
the sum of the sparsity is true because
some regions of the region
some regions of the genome don't
interact with each other
and another typical data characteristic
is uh what we call the genomic distance
effect as you can imagine genes that are
regions of the genome that are nearby
each other are just likely to interact
more by chance so this is known as the
genomic distance effect and it's usually
visualized by
by
quantifying the interaction frequency
between genomic loci as a function of
the genomic distance between them so
this is what it looks like in bulk um
and we naturally we looked at this in
the single cell world
i have two cell types here and then the
cells are generally cells are separated
depending on their uh their sequencing
depth and then each line represents a
single cell and the color depicts this
you know the library size or the
sequencing depth of the cell and as you
can see we also see the genomic distance
effect but perhaps it's affected both by
the library size and actually the
genomic distance and then maybe an
interaction between those so this is
like one of the typical explanatory
plots we would do and then to further
motivate our modeling we actually fit a
mixed effects model um
this data where we allowed variation uh
cell specific variation and then ask
whether you know we can capture the
interaction frequency between genomic
loci with cell type library size band
which which is a a proxy for the genomic
distance and the interaction between
them so we consider as you know a large
set of models and
in all the models uh including an
interaction between the library size and
the band really help so this is
something to keep in mind as we go
forward um
so with these observations in mind we
we said we'll start with something super
simple so that's one end of the spectrum
in terms of normalizing this data and
then we'll do something fancy you know
adapting things from
deep generative modeling for single cell
data so
towards this we develop band norm and
scvi 3d um
both of these operate by
working on this what we call band
transformation where we essentially
take genomic loci that are equidistant
from each other and then organize them
in these uh locus pair by cell matrices
so we would take all the purple bands
from these contact matrices organize
them like this and then take the next
band and so on and so forth and a band
norm is a super simple uh it basically
uh within each band it adjusts for the
library size
of the cells within the band matrix and
then across the band matrices and then
on top of that to allow um
the effect that you know perhaps this
band decay is something that can vary
from cell to cell it add adds back a
band decay estimate that's essentially
an average of these band matrices
so it's really not doing anything
specific it's scaling and then adding
band the band decay uh
to
allow that perhaps some south specific
than decay and also perhaps give a
little bit more weight to the
interactions that are more close to each
other
and then so that's one end of the
spectrum at the other end of the
spectrum we actually took scvi
we heard a lot
we heard a lot of mentioning of svi
yesterday and then we modified it for
our purposes
so we can do this because we have seen
that these
uh interactions that we see at locus
pairs are modulated by both library size
and
band so for each band matrix we assume
that locus specific counts come from a
folsom comma mixture model where we have
a local specific rate parameter which is
modulated by the cell and library size
and then this modulating parameter is
coming from a log normal distribution
and we also made the uh zero inflation
probability locus specific because some
of the zeros are going to be
just because you know they are coming
from heterochromatin regions and so on
and so forth
and then um just going basically over it
then we assume that these key parameters
of the parametric models uh are actually
non-linear functions of these latent
variables uh that capture uh cells
characteristics so we made um so we make
this a probability of zero inflation and
the shape parameter of the gamma
distribution for the mean rate parameter
depend on nonlinear functions of these
latent variables that are cell and band
specific and then finally the um
these latent variables are coming from
gaussian distributions so if you if you
know scvi so this is actually just one
of the models of scvi
applied at the band level okay so for us
this was important to realize and then
also justifies with the band and libra
size interaction because then we can fit
this model with scvi tools
so um
i'll just some show you some examples of
how these work in practice i'll compare
this with a number of different methods
uh so there's now quite a bit of
activity in structuring model structured
modeling of single cell high c data scic
cluster is one of the earlier models it
does some linear smoothing and random
work to impute sdic topics is a topics
model
and higashi is a really innovator of
hyper graph model from jian's lab and
then we have sc vi 3d and in addition to
this you know we have band norm that
sequencing that normalizes and adds back
band decay we considered even dump
alternatives where we are just adjusting
for library size and then adjusting for
library size in a band aware manner but
then not adding back to decay constant
okay and then these all generate oh and
then one final thing is you know none of
these scaling approaches take into
account the matrix structure of the data
so then we said okay let's add maybe
some graph convolutional network there
to see whether that would make a
difference and then as i'll put these
methods um
either provide low dimensional
embeddings and denoised data or just
normalized or denoised data so there are
a lot of details
in terms of fitting these models how the
cells are filtering so we try to unify
all of those
and then our manuscript has all the
details
in terms of evaluation so one basic
evaluation we can do is you know given a
single cell ic data set where we know
the cell types we can try to see after
you know
normalization and denoising can we
capture the known cell types and then we
can also evaluate all sorts of impact of
the noising and normalization on the
downstream um
or the downstream analysis so i'll show
you uh examples of these two and all of
these other evaluations are in our
manuscript
[Music]
so
so i'll start with this data set which
is uh basically just profiling uh
a bunch of cell lines you know we have a
different number of cells four different
cell lines ion we have very small number
of cells for imr 90 which kind of plays
the role of a rare cell type and then as
we can see so all of the methods few
maps of all of the methods are
low dimensional embeddings are
depicted here uh so all the methods have
you know problem with this imranit which
has you know like very small number of
cells and then in terms of the methods
that work on just based on scaling then
norm does better than the others and
actually it works as well as other
more structured modeling approaches
and then this is another data set again
looking at these cell types where now
you have two of the cell lines at very
sequence very low number of cells
and
then norm is ci cluster and then uh
cells get coupled with cnn and scvi 3d
they actually recapitulate three of the
cell lines okay and then the other cell
line gets mixed up because again it has
2p representation whereas these other
methods can only calculate the two cell
lines
so now this is more like a real example
where now we are looking at uh
uh
we are looking at uh
some mouse brain we are looking at a
human data from human prefrontal cortex
which is much more complicated and the
original publication this is this is
data from uh joe ecker's lab uh
indicated that you know it was very hard
to separate exacerbal subtypes and
inhibitor subtypes just based on single
cell high c
uh but we actually can see that uh
a subset of the methods do actually a
pretty good job in separating these two
big group of exercise excitatory and
inhibitory subtypes
and furthermore uh so
all of these were at one megabase
resolution so which is perhaps not
that useful in terms of learning
regulatory interactions but certainly
useful in terms of learning uh tid
boundaries and so on so we said okay
could we push the limit to um
100 kb and then when we do that methods
that have intrinsic imputation
higashi cic cluster and svi 3d still
preserve their performances but then
norm which was our you know really
simple uh simplistic method it it starts
to suffer because this now becomes too
sparse for it to handle
and then we evaluated these methods uh
on you know these four
big data sets and also with different
type of metrics
and there's one data set from being
grants group
it has small number of cells and
probably some confounding issues uh but
despite that band norm which which is
not doing anything fancy it appeared to
perform the best on that um
and then if we you know if we want to
aggregate all these evaluations we see
that then norm performs the best
followed by
higashi and scbi 3d
and one thing about band norm is that we
think of it as you know like the initial
method you might want to apply to check
data quality because it you know it runs
in 15 minutes literally it's like no
cost whereas these methods if you have
gpu large cores they can run within an
hour uh but you know they require um
leather hardware
so then i'll refer you to these um our
our paper for this additional analysis
oh actually actually okay so actually
i'm
let's see i want to also show uh how the
uh after denoising how the aggregated
single cell matrices compare with the
balconified high c data so you know
after we normalize nd noise we can
aggregate the um single cell high c data
and then compare it with the you know um
bulk fight
with the actual bulk ic data um
so we have done that for again many
different data sets so i'm showing an
example for an abundant cell type um in
this in this particular data set and we
can see that
uh here the upper triangle is the actual
bulk ic data coming from a different
experiment different source and then the
lower triangle is the
aggregated or pseudobulk coming from
denoise and normalized ic data so we see
that maybe higashi is a little bit of
over imputation but overall the methods
look pretty decent
in terms of capturing the
bulk ic
however if we go to a rare cell type
again band norm has a lot of sparsity
issues
and the scic is maybe a cluster is maybe
a little blurry and higashi again we
think it has a little bit of over
smoothing issues and
scvi 3d performs um
well it usually looks just right that's
one way to put it and then we compare
the uh
bulkified pseudo to bulk uh and then we
see that overall band norm seems the
best uh and it's comparable to scvi 3d
and then as the um
higashi souls
higashi shows quite a bit of variability
across the chromosome so here each data
point is a chromosome
score that compares bulkified and about
version
with a particular chromosome and as the
as the cell type gets rare then band
norm also starts to perform similar to
the others
now i can um
be a little late no okay
all right so um
so the the the the the and the uh
i'm i'm particularly excited about now
our potential uh to integrate hcic data
with other single cell modalities
especially you know for you know
tissue tissue samples uh we can see that
you know identifying sub-cell types
could be tricky um so we naturally first
wanted to integrate this with single
cell rna-seq because there's just so
many of that and again we want to
improve cell type annotation and then
also maybe and
understand long-range interactions
between genes and enhancers
and
so in order to do this uh
we so we our first step at this was you
know take this uh scic
data which is now here vectorized we
have the locus pairs and this local
sphere representation is good for
different type of downstream analysis
but in our first step we said okay maybe
there's a way to summarize scic data at
the level of genes
so we considered a bunch of different
metrics to do that a natural idea is to
consider gene body and promoter and
count up all the interactions that
originate from this region and then of
course we have to make sure that we make
this number comparable with other
comparable across genes one way to do
that is to adjust these
gene you know interactions that are in
the gene body and promoter with the
local background perhaps estimated by
regions of the same size in the upstream
and up downstream of the region so a
bulk version of this was actually uh
was actually mentioned in this paper um
and then uh we could also do something
more explicit you know adjust these for
uh gc content mobility and gene length
gc content and ability are standard
genomic biases uh
and then we said uh since we are looking
at a population of cells with different
cell types maybe we can just you know
use the average interaction of a cell
across all the cells as its background
so if we have enough number of cells
from different cell types that would
work well so that basically comes down
to standardizing adjusting for the
sequencing depth of the cells and then
standardizing across genes
so i'll show you how that performs so
this is the role without any adjustment
this is if we estimate a local
background this is the regression
approach and this is the standardization
approach so overall it seemed to work
quite well so we decided to go with this
standardization approach and then next
we ask whether this
single cell gene associating domain you
know which captures interactions from
gene bodies and promoters is it a good
proxy for gene expression we um
we aggregated
the g we aggregated genes
scga d scores across cells and then
expression across genes and looked at
the correlation of these and we see
pretty decent correlations that you know
recapitulate the correlations that you
would see in the gene activity scores
from a toxic and um
single cell anaesic
and a furthermore if we take marker
genes defined from
singles that are an asic and aggregate
the single cell gene associating domain
scores of
those marker genes we can see that they
actually have very nice cell type
specificity
so this gave us more confidence that
these scgad scores are actually good
proxies for gene expression
um
so
shows one of these experiments then then
we took you know uh
different singles on asic data sets and
high c data sets
and then did this joint uh integration
so we looked at a you know similar
system from the same lab
a similar system from different labs uh
and then we also even looked at uh a
single cell chipseek particularly k27
acetylation and k for methylation and we
also looked at human
prefrontal cortex so i'll show you one
of these in the interest of the time
so this is um
so the data is coming to from the same
lab but high c and rna-seq are profiled
separately
and
once we converted our high c single cell
high c to gene level features then we
again our first step at this we use
thorax canonical correlations approach
to do the joint integration so this on
the left hand side is the projection
of both single cell high c and rna-seq
onto the same space and it's a little
bit easier if we color the cells uh
based on their source whether they are
single cell ic or an ac and we see that
they are nicely
mixed
uh the data sources are nicely mixed and
then we can look at single cell rna-seq
separately and high c separately and
then we see that similar cell types are
clustered together and one thing is uh
why this we found this quite interesting
is that in the original publication
there were these group of cells just
based on high c they were labeled as
neonatal neuron one neonatal neuron two
so no more you know no further
annotation was done on these and once we
project on this space we actually can
see that some of these are interneurons
you know some of them are more like
hippocampal pyramidal cells and so on so
there's definitely a lot of room in
terms of improving the annotation
so the rest are really similar and just
to
point we can do this with single cell
chipseq epigenome profiling too we can
do that very nicely
and uh we have also available
so just to recap this regulation theme
uh single cell high c is just adding
another data modality uh the technology
is still improving uh but you know some
of the most recent data sets and recent
protocols are really
promising um
and uh
so we have observed that we can
summarize single cell high z at the gene
level as meaningful features uh this
enabled you know integration with other
data modalities but we think there's
actually a lot of room uh
for methods that do not necessarily do
this type of feature level mapping
before integration
i'll stop there and i'll acknowledge uh
so this is the work of uh si chi shan
from my group and yes zhang a former
member of my group
at fred hutch
she's been there for a while and you
know dived into more single-cell stuff
and if you guys are uh hiring if any of
your departments are hiring she's a real
catch
and i'll stop there thank you
any questions
i think he's in this very nice talk so i
think following from elizabeth talk
yesterday i wonder if there are data
where cells are measured for both high c
and rna-seq
that i don't think we have yet but we
have high c and methylation
let's see as far as i know we don't have
um high c and rnac i see yes please i
see because i feel like probably
your scvi framework it seems that which
is what elizabeth also used for her
joint embedding
yesterday right it could be something
that's doable for the integration part
if we don't want to convert high c data
to a one-dimensional gene score right
first yeah yeah so yeah that definitely
i think there is room so we have efforts
in that area uh but we don't have
results yet so we were just you know
again exploring the data you know is is
there a way to really reduce it to gene
level features and you know we were
happy to see that sdgad seems to be
doing really well but there's definitely
room for improvement right and i think
another possible thing to do for hi-c
data is to use the
known enhancer notations because if we
think the heist indicates enhancer
promoter interactions
that's true but probably we don't have
that resolution yet so one of the best
data sets you can go to 10 kb resolution
and that might be okay uh but you know
going to do truly the enhancer level we
probably need to improve imputation
methods or you know
generate better quality data
okay thank you
yeah so it's it's a quick question i
think uh so when you do the seal the
book to try to recapitulate uh the bulb
information um
in the case of rare sales
which is the minimum number of cells you
need to actually build a
believable map
like
yeah so i think hundreds are i think
yeah so hundreds are okay it's just that
if you have
other cell types in the thousands they
dominate uh but otherwise i think
hundreds of cells you know few hundreds
they they produce pretty decent contact
maps
thanks
just a comment on the
over imputation
issue that you mentioned yeah
for hagashi i think it's
you know i think we can discuss more but
my opinion is that
you have i think if you just compare
with the bulk ic it may not be the right
way to evaluate that in a way that the
bulk ic has to be enhanced also because
in single cell contact map try to
enhance that and you see let's say a
contact an entry there
and in bulk you may not see that or you
know it's obscured because of some other
issues
i think that's
and we can discuss it i think i think
it's it's perhaps a research topic like
how to you evaluate that by comparing to
fall crisis my question is for the
single cell g8
right
i notice that you applied to this um
dipsy which is very very very high
coverage
if you apply to a
you know lower quality one like the
jowacker's previous
data system human prefrontal cortex what
it what does that look like
in terms of the separation of the
cell types i know that our experiences
with the dip see if you don't use
any trick you just use their you know
single cell a b compartmization score
you can already separate the cell types
quite well so that's a very good
question and i actually had a slide so
we have done some experiments to
investigate that so you know
keep your singles rna-seq fixed and then
vary the single cell high c data so we
varied the number of reads and also the
you know number of genes features that
we are using so we can see that and this
is from eckers data just focusing on
major cell types performance throws
drops if we
if we focus on uh
you know
more sub-cell types the pattern is the
same but the overall numbers drop so we
see that of course the you know number
of reads uh the
has has the huge impact so as here these
three major cell types are nice and
separated and they start to mix uh
and then
but this can you know just using
changing the number of features you are
using it actually helps to alleviate
that drop and when we evaluated this
with the you know transfer label
accuracy where you uh where you um train
a model based on single cell rna-seq and
try to infer
cell labels for the single cell high c
so the you know accuracy goes from 0.9
to 0.68 it's a drop but it's actually
not that dramatic
i wonder if you started thinking it's
kind of like a next step after this but
if you started thinking about um
what you can learn biologically from
single cell that you're missing in other
data types besides you know maybe
slightly better clustering of cell types
for example
you know if you look across genes
there's generally a correlation between
your god score and
gene expression but there's many genes
that are not right on the diagonal are
they certain functions certain parts of
the genome can we learn something
that you wouldn't pick up either in bulk
or that you wouldn't pick up with
something like a taxi like just how open
is the chromatin on the gene body
is there some information in this data
do you think
i think so i think we will learn more um
more
i don't want to say sub-cell types but
states probably you know cell states uh
where even though it's the same cell
type
in terms of the 3d chromatin structure a
subset of the cells would look different
for you know a number of reasons we
haven't really dived deeply into that
but i think you know that's the kind of
thing that we want to learn from single
cells oh cool so you think there would
be information that wouldn't be in
single cell attack that would be really
specific to genome folding
in single cell single cell a taxi
would tell you that the gene body is
open or closed um your triangle is
basically also measuring that but is
there something more do you think like
about
than just measuring how open is the
chromatin i think so but i think we have
to go beyond single cell gad for that i
think you know we have to integrate uh
maybe focus on more uh
not just the integration as an aggregate
score but uh really pick up uh what
uh what enhancers
should contribute to a it should
contribute a gene's gad score i think
that can tell us uh that can tell us
more cool because from attack
it's hard to um
from single cell attack it's hard to
identify these long-range interactions
just yeah just one dimensional situation
you get something but it's really hard
yeah so i think with this instead of
just getting an aggregate score if we
can tease out for a given gene what
long-range interactions are actually
associating with that gene
then uh
then you know that might provide an
explanation for these sub-cell states
cool awesome and just a quick comment to
that jessica's question snare seek for
example does measure single cell rna and
high c in the same cell type and john
what else there's some other
technologies i've mostly used scenarios
snare attack i think it doesn't do the
both okay i thought there was now a
version that did high c but maybe i'm
wrong like a snare high c or something
there is imaging right so there is
imaging but
yeah
yeah i'm trying to remember maybe that's
the wrong name it's like uh from
maybe it is high cart yeah
i'm the one that's
okay the other one that does the um
like the psy hi-c that vj romani like
the first paper she cited from early
ones i think there's now a version of
that where they take the cell pools and
put them
sequentially into different wells and
put a series of barcodes
that is unique enough to trace back to
like the single cell i thought there was
a version but maybe i'm wrong it does
rna and high c
okay so maybe not yet okay and not that
i know but there is imaging
and high c together so there is some you
know early works like 2000 datas
[Applause]